Let's be honest, many of us sit indoors .. throughout the day.
Either to work or to enjoy watching the latest television series, we simply go out
Much. But what happens if we stop going abroad together?
149600000 km of sunlight is removed from the sun, and launched through the solar system
During our air cover, if the timing is correct, it will come down directly on your skin. Feeling
Well, right? These sunrays are a series of amazing interactions, which help
To maintain your life: "Vitamin sunlight" Vitamin D.
Interestingly, some of the cholesterol you consume modifies and stores in your skin
When these supernova rays collide with your skin, they change it
Cholesterol. New molecules travel through the blood stream to the liver, and there
It changes again, and then into the kidneys, where it activates biologically.
Activated vitamin D works to absorb calcium from your food, eventually leading to bone building
And strengthen it. Somehow, your skin eats the sun and the sun is developing your bones! Probably
We are not very different from the plant. Without Vitine D, your body will not only suffer
Of the lack of minerals in your bones, and leads to diseases such as osteoporosis but
You will also see a decrease in immune function. And more, there is evidence that suggests vitamin
D. Helps prevent cancer, heart disease and depression. Which probably explains why people are in
The colder areas with the lack of daylight light often suffer from "winter blue"
But not just the sun's rays and vitamin D, which make the difference. Many studies have shown
That your presence in nature has psychological and physical effects on your body. While using
Advanced brain imaging techniques show that the brain in nature has higher activity in associated brain regions
Stability, compassion and love. On the other hand, it has shown that the man-made environment is produced
Energy in brain regions associated with fear and anxiety.
On top of all this, if you are often inside you are likely to be sitting. I admit you
I was laid back, watching YouTube for hours. Which may seem harmless, but studies
Showed that there was a significant health impact associated with sitting time such as height in type II
Of diabetes and cardiovascular disease. And two other things, a study consisting of more than 200,000 people found
A strong relationship between mortality and long sitting time - in other words
The more you sit, the more likely you are to die early. The most frightening part is that
Be regardless of your physical activity. So stand up, go outside and live a little bit
Longer than you will get. After subscribing to our channel and watching
All videos, that is! This episode is supported by numberspace.com.
Squarespace allows you to create your own personal website quickly and easily
You can create your site in just a few minutes
Using one of their molded designs. I have Squarespace
Drag and drop tools enable you to customize everything in your site such as colors and layout
With a few clicks. If you want more help with the Squarespace excellent support team available 24/7
For a free trial and a 10% discount. squarespace.com Use the code asap8. Thanks again for squarespace.com
For their support AsapSCIENCE, subscribe to more weekly scientific sections